so as we pick up with age of Ultron
issue number three we start off with
she-hulk
and Luke Cage and it seems as though
whatever it is is going on here may be
part of the plan that was presumably
created by Captain America and again
what we see is that Luke Cage as
she-hulk if she sees anything presumably
whether or not she sees any Ultron
robots and and and she-hulk says no says
that she doesn't actually see anybody
and so what Luke Cage tells her is to
simply just brace herself to go limp and
it seems as though the reason why is
because he's going to punch her as hard
as he possibly can but if she braces
herself for the impact she's not going
to be knocked out so as long as she goes
limp it he can hit her as hard as he can
then she'll most likely fall unconscious
and so what we see is that when this
happens when Luke Cage punches her as
hard as he possibly can that the result
is that the immediate area begins to
shake due to the impact now half of this
is due to the indestructible skin that
Luke Cage has and the incredible
strength that he has along with it and
the other half is that we just due to
the sheer force of impact against a
being as strong as she Hulk and so we
see that she hope falls unconscious and
Luke Cage picks her up to presumably
carry her back to where all Tron is at
this point we jump back through a
flashback from Luke Cage to about an
hour before we started this story and
what spider-man is saying here is that
everybody more or less just kind of
needs to suck it up that everybody just
sort of needs to get it together and
they need to go back on the offensive
and try to fight Ultron Emma Frost
replies by saying that it's just not
that easy that there are so few of them
left that they would probably be wiped
out almost immediately that individuals
like Scott Summers are gone and we see
of course that it's chimed in that Thor
is gone that the Incredible Hulk Bruce
Banner is gone and that Ben Grimm is
gone and so for the most part the most
physically powerful individuals they
have the I guess the foundation of
powerhouses that they have within the
superhero universe are gone that there's
really no way for anybody to physically
go toe-to-toe with any of the Ultron
robots and so all you really have left
on their side is their intellect is
their ability to be cunning the Spider
Man asked Luke Cage about Jessica Jones
and their newborn baby and Luke Cage
doesn't reply but we see that Luke Cage
is kind of crying to himself as he's a
les retelling us this story indicating
that Jessica Jones and his newborn baby
were both killed in the initial attack
by Ultron from here we see Captain
America saying that things are the way
they are now because they didn't have a
plan before they didn't have a plan
before the arrival of Peter Parker and
that the idea here is to give them
something to trade is to give Ultron
something to barter with now what we'll
learn is that initially it's not the
idea to simply just barter the Captain
America has a second point to this to
this plan and Hawkeye asks him what it
is they should barter for and spider-man
continues again with a little prodding
from my Captain America to retell what
it was that he had told them previously
that the owl as spider-man had overheard
it was able to maintain his operations
they were able to continue doing
whatever was that they were doing before
as long as they made payments to Ultron
and the payments were in the form of
superheroes and so most likely a large
majority of the superheroes or even
supervillains who had been killed were
probably killed by the owl and various
other people who were selling them off
in order to keep themselves alive
and again Emma Frost continues by saying
that arm sorry storm continues by saying
that nobody's answering her question now
the question here is why wouldn't all
Tron simply just kill everyone
why wouldn't all try and simply just
wipe everybody out why would he go
through all the trouble to to simply
ruin the world and Tony Stark chimes in
by saying that he knows exactly why
Ultron hasn't simply just killed
everyone and what Tony Stark gives us is
some really interesting insight into
Ultron and it's probably the answer to
the question that a lot of you guys are
asking of why is it that Ultron hasn't
killed everyone what Tony Stark's tells
us is that Ultron was created to have
human needs and desires and that he
thinks that what Ultron is doing right
now is replicating what he thinks needs
and desires are so the idea of revenge
of torture so on and so forth that these
are all ideas that Ultron has programmed
himself to believe and so he's acting
out effectively the way that he thinks a
human would act out and so he asked the
question let's say that Ultron won and
that he took over the world then what
would happen and Emma Frost replies by
saying that it simply just wouldn't be
enough and so the idea here is that
Ultron is more or less establishing
himself as a dictator
and living out the role of a dictator
but that they're not really sure exactly
what the end result of all this is going
to be and so from here we see that that
that Hawkeye replies by saying that this
is all Hank PEM's fault and again Tony
Stark slides on with him here he says
that it's not necessarily Hank Penn's
fault and Hawkeye gets angry here
Hawkeye says that who else's fault would
it be that it's not the fault of anybody
else aside from Hank Pym because Hank
hem was the one who created Ultron now
again if you recall our discussion about
Ultron we had talked about how when he
was first created by Hank Pym that
almost immediately Ultron rebelled but
then Ultron had modified the memories of
Hank hem so that Hank Pym would never
remember the fact that he made Ultron
and so by the time Ultron had reimbursed
with Ultron number five that he was far
more advanced that he had previously
been and was an almost unstoppable force
so he could simply just be held off but
that he can never really be killed
because he would simply just
reconstitute himself in one form or
another and so again more or less what's
taking place here is this I guess
intervention or this intervening of
Captain America and saying that none of
what's going on matters anymore that
none of this arguing and this debating
matters that what matters is that it's
time to make a plan that if Ultron is
buying and selling people if he is
taking trades if he is allowing people
to continue their operations as long as
they give ultron superheroes or
super-powered beings then he says why
not just give him one of them why not
have one of them had be handed in more
or less and will reign chimes in and
says that that can't really get them
that far into Ultron's world but again
we see I guess this idea more or less
coming to fruition where the idea is
maybe one of them can get further inside
than they normally would that maybe one
of them would be able to get deep inside
the base of Ultron and be able to
actually influence or be able to
initiate some incredible damage here be
able to initiate some I guess a set of
circumstances more or less whereby
Ultron would could effectively be
destroyed and so we see that again
Hawkeye chimes in and
says that he doesn't really know how
successful this would be he doesn't know
how powerful an individual would have to
be in order to actually get in there and
to inflict some damage and so what we
see Wolverine saying is that it would
have to be somebody and credibly
powerful here it would have to be
somebody very very strong somebody
durable somebody's sturdy somebody who
is nigh indestructible and so we
immediately see that she-hulk and Luke
Cage volunteer themselves in order to go
in and to try to infiltrate Ultron's
base and initially the idea is no that
that that she hoax should be the one to
do it
but again Luke Cage says that he has an
indestructible skin he has the the
ability more or less to not be killed
but again the she-hulk says that she's
the stronger of the two now what's very
interesting about this entire set of
circumstances here and something that I
hope you picked up is that Maria Hill is
part of the team here Maria Hill is part
of these forces she's part of this
superhero group or this group of
individuals who are trying to stay alive
and what this more or less tells us is
that the idea of enemies the idea of
allies isn't really something that
exists here is people who were simply
just trying to live and so again we see
that Emma Frost uses her ability to read
the mind of others and tell everybody
that Tony Stark is going to say that
it's not going to work that this is not
going to to be successful that neither
of them are going and Tony Stark says
yes he says that this is only half a
plan that it's not a full plan and that
it's not worth the life of another
person but then we see she-hulk
overruling him by simply saying that
she's not going to just sit around that
the idea of waiting to die is worse than
simply going out and doing something
that may result in them dying and so she
wants to do something she wants to get
involved somehow she wants to be the one
that breaks into Ultron's fortress and
so Luke 8 says okay and says that he'll
be the one that'll take her but
Wolverine says no Wolverine says that he
should be the one to take she-hulk but
then we see Captain America saying that
this would be a ridiculous thing to do
because Wolverine has adamantium laced
skin and that automatic release bones
rather and that Ultron would immediately
take Wolverine he wouldn't even allow
Wolverine to be too
and she Hulk over that he would take
Wolverine and he would dissect Wolverine
and uses adamantium possibly even try to
find a way to replicate it and use it
for his own means and so somebody else
needs to go along somebody that can hand
she Hulk over and then walk away and so
the idea here is that they're going to
stick with Luke Cage that Luke Cage is
going to be the one to hand she Hulk
over to Ultron from here we see them
trying to decide where to go next that
because they're going to be leaving the
space but they can't come back here and
so Captain America says they should go
to the mutate village and Savage Land
and that for the most part while he
believes that it's not necessarily been
conquered by Ultron that the possibility
remains but that's a possibility that
they're going to have to take a gamble
on and so we see that again she-hulk and
Luke Cage set out to complete this plan
that's been laid out by Captain America
at this point we pick up with Luke Cage
as he's as he's carrying she-hulk back
to Ultron's base and as Luke Cage
approaches the the base several Ultron
robots arrive and Luke Cage says that he
has a Hulk and that he wants to trade
from here we transition to Chicago and
when we pick up with Chicago we see this
some individual is more or less
detecting the fact that the air is
poison here that the air is most likely
irradiated now this is probably due to
maybe some kind of nuclear devastation
some kind of nuclear fallout we don't
really know but we learned that of the
individuals who were here that we're
currently seeing black panther
Thunderbolt Ross as Red Hulk and the
taskmaster and again the taskmasters
involvement here more or less tells us
that there really are no no enemies here
that really are no villains here that is
simply just people trying to survive and
so what we see a taskmaster observing is
that there is an Ultron robot down on
the that amount on a half away alongside
some individual some kind of human now
whether or not this is a superpower
being is something we don't know but we
see that Thunderbolt Ross immediately
takes off and goes after this Ultron
robot which appears to have been the
plan now why it is he's doing this is
something we don't know but we learned
that during the conflict I guess during
the fight between Thunderbolt Ross and
his Ultron robot that he tears the
robots head off
and with the robots head comes what
appears to be a kind of makeshift spinal
cord and the intention as its explained
to us seems to be that black panther and
hag mad a taskmaster are going to use
this head of Ultron to perhaps try to
find some way to defeat the other Ultron
robots or even Ultron itself and so for
the most part we see that while
Thunderbolt Ross is overwhelmed by the
arrival of other Ultron robots that a
taskmaster and black panther immediately
run for it at the behest of a
Thunderbolt Ross to leave him behind
from this point we transitioned back to
New York with Luke Cage and and she-hulk
and Luke Cage is heading back into the
major fortress or I guess into the main
base of Ultron which apparently resides
within Times Square and once he actually
gets inside of the building we learn a
very disturbing fact what we learn here
is that it's not in fact Ultron that's
running the show that it is in fact
vision now we don't know exactly at this
moment why it is that vision is here or
why vision is the one that's actually
taking the place of Ultron that'll
actually be some of this explained to us
in age of Ultron issue number 4 but with
that we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace